thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode
of journey to the microcosmos and if you
are one of the first thousand people to
click the link in the description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
there are so so so many microbes
in the world this far into our journey
it's kind of astonishing to think that
for all of the exciting and odd
creatures we've watched
we've only kind of dipped into the
shallows
of the micro cosmos
[Music]
and like have you ever sat back and been
overwhelmed by the enormity
of this miniscule world of just how many
organisms are
out there both known and unknown
whose lives have been sustaining
ecosystems and changing climates and
doing
just so much stuff for eons and eons has
this
diverse invisible mass
scientists have been parsing through
this overwhelming world for a few
centuries now
identifying the specifics of how
individual organisms
live and connecting them to the bigger
picture
of how our world works but what we
especially love to do with the
natural world is categorize
and perhaps the most familiar image of
the categories we've created
is the phylogenetic tree the goal
of phylogenetic trees is to track the
organisms we know of
through their place in evolution take
for example these various
corkscrew-shaped bacteria
members of the spirochetes phylum
this phylogenetic tree is from the 90s
and has been updated with more data but
we'll use it
just for now because it's relatively
simple and that's useful in explaining
how
the trees themselves work the ends of
these trees
are the various spirochetes that
scientists have been able to study
and if you move to the left you can see
their branches
coming to an unnamed ancestor shared
with
other similar spirochetes these
ancestors then branch
back and connect with each other in
various structures
creating that oh so familiar tree-like
structure
and at the bottom is e coli which
functions
here as an out-group a useful reference
as something not
immediately part of the spirochete
phylum
we use these diagrams along with the
words
kingdom and phylum to categorize
everything from the tiniest microbe
to the largest whale but it's important
to remember that these
trees are our interpretation of what
we've seen
nature didn't set out to create kingdoms
and
phylums those are categories we created
to help us make sense of the natural
world
it takes a lot of complex work to
simplify nature in this way
and the process behind creating these
evolutionary trees
has itself been an evolving one
in the days of darwin evolution was
connected
to the things we could see and when it
comes to macroscopic animals the things
we see
like anatomy and fossils are very useful
microbes though are a bit tougher when
we first began observing them
we tried to understand them with words
we already knew
which led to confusion over whether they
should be considered
tiny plants or tiny animals but with
time and more observations
scientists began to divide these
organisms and really
all of life into two overarching
categories
bacteria and eukaryotes
this dichotomy would be most obvious in
the microcosmos but these divisions were
still
just a container that hid a confusing
array of connections
bacteria for example might be grouped
together according to all sorts of
factors like
their ability to form colonies or the
danger they pose to humans
but it hadn't always been clear that the
commonality of these traits
necessarily links in any way to how they
evolved
we've seen this again and again in our
journey through the micro cosmos
in the amoebas and euglenoids and so
many other organisms whose evolutionary
connections
seem straightforward based on their
morphology
and then inevitably we bring out the
source of so many plot twists
we're talking about molecular phylogeny
and the host of techniques it
encompasses
to reveal genetic connections that our
eyes
cannot see but molecular phylogeny
doesn't just
show us a whole bunch of things we got
wrong
it's helped reveal new categories and
relationships within the microcosmos
the seminal work behind these techniques
was published by carl
woes and george fox in 1977
and it was rooted in a straightforward
but powerful notion
that the sequences of molecules inside
microbes
could help us make connections that
their morphology
could not this wasn't a new idea
scientists had been linking amino acid
sequences between
animals but the real challenge lay in
figuring out
what molecular sequence would actually
be best to accomplish this goal in
microbes
we needed something universal enough
to connect all organisms but also simple
enough
to compare using the sequencing methods
available at the time
so woes suggested an organelle
that you might not think of all that
often the ribosome
across all living cells ribosomes
are the protein factory taking in
rna and translating it into the
molecules
that make our bodies and all
life work and the ribosome itself
has an interesting structure made up of
both protein
and rna woes and fox
picked out a particular subset of that
ribosomal rna
compare the sequence different organisms
used to construct that segment
and then built a phylogenetic tree out
of the similarities
and differences in that sequence
their results did more than just create
a tree though it revealed a whole
new subset of life that lay
outside what we had assumed to be the
binary divide
between bacteria and eukaryotes they
had uncovered the archaea a type of
prokaryote that had been assumed up to
that point to be
a strange type of extremophile bacteria
but thanks to archaea's ribosomal rna
and additional understanding of their
morphology
woes and fox realized that they were
separate
from bacteria an entire new
domain of life molecular phylogenetic
techniques have
gone on to shift our understanding of
microbes
raising questions and providing insights
into how
everything from sex to eating have
evolved
but there are still many other methods
of evolution that may not be captured
by these techniques including of course
endosymbiogenesis and horizontal gene
transfer everybody's two favorite
non-linear methods
of evolution establishing these
phylogenetic trees
for all that it has helped us simplify
nature
also emphasizes just how many
complexities
we cannot easily illustrate connecting
organisms through their evolutionary
relationships
helps us establish a history of nature
and map
out the microbial world as it exists
today
that map will likely never be complete
but the work that goes into it helps us
navigate through time
and space and through invisible lives
long gone to see how our world today
is connected to the microcosmos
of the past thank you for coming on this
journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
a lot of us are working at home right
now and for many people
it's the first time they're experiencing
the work from home lifestyle
one of the biggest struggles with
working from home is making sure you're
still
able to be productive while living
working
and spending the majority of your time
all in the same place
thomas frank is a youtuber who knows a
lot about productivity and over on
skillshare
he teaches the incredibly helpful
productivity master class
he'll walk you through the steps to
setting up your own productivity system
to help you be better at making to-do
lists organizing your
files both physical and digital as well
as tackling the dreaded world
of your email inbox skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership
with meaning with so much to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and it makes it easy with short classes
that'll fit into your daily routine
a premium membership will give you
unlimited access so you can join the
classes and communities
that are right for you and an annual
subscription to skillshare is less than
ten dollars a month
and if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
thank you to all the people here on the
screen they
are our patreon patrons and they're the
reason why we are able to make
this show this is the last episode of
season two of journey to the micro
cosmos we're going to take a couple of
weeks off
but then we will be back on august 10th
with a new
episode if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes james check out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you